this was Nicola bully on the morning she
disappeared
with her dog Willow just visible in the
boot these images are from the family's
home security camera
it shows the missing mum wearing the
clothes she was last seen in
preparing to drive her daughters to
school
that was 10 days ago
[Applause]
and her family are desperate for answers
Saturday like us Nicola Bully's family
spotted a police search helicopter above
the village where she went missing
her partner Paul shared the moment with
Sky News when their youngest daughter
Sophia saw it too from the car window
Nicola Bully's daughters Harriet and
Sophia are nine and six we're all a
group of mums most of our children all
attend the same school they are girls
full of questions about when they'll see
Mummy
hard for them they've got all the same
emotions as everybody else and they want
to see them on and they don't know where
she is and
um you know they just desperately want a
home and I guess that's all they're
asking all the time is
where is she and is she coming to home
yeah today the local church held its
usual family service friends tell us
they're trying to keep things as normal
as possible for their missing friends
daughters like taking them to the school
disco that went ahead on Friday night
life has got to go on for the sake of
the children doesn't it the children
Force us to carry on sometimes and so
while that was happening a lot of the
parents came here to church when we
began this and we'll keep the uh the
candles lit for as long as it takes
it is now day 10 into the investigation
into what happened to Nicola bully and
the search continues to be focused
around here the river wire where she was
last seen walking today her family and
friends have told us that even now they
still have hope that she will be brought
home safely
the police's main working theory is
unchanged that Nicola bully fell into
the river as they search the lancash
force also condemned what they called
speculation and abuse on social media
aimed at some people who are merely
assisting our inquiries they appeal for
witnesses to keep coming forward and
help provide much longed for answers
Catherine avatarsi Sky News Lancashire